us humans seem to uh utilize it well but
you say it's also very important early
on is sex
so uh what is sex uh just asking for a
friend
and when was it invented and how hard
was it to invent just as you were saying
and why was it invented
why
how hard was it and when
i have a phd student who's been working
on this and we've just asked a couple of
papers on sex yes yes yes what do you
publish these those biology is it
biology genetics journals yeah it's like
this is actually pnas which is
proceedings of the national catalan
broad big big picture everyone's
interested in sex yeah the the job of
biologists is to make sex dull
yes yeah that's a beautiful way to put
it okay so when was it invented
it was invented with eukaryotes about
two billion years ago
um all eukaryotes
share the same basic mechanism that you
produce gametes the gametes fuse
together so the gamete is the egg cell
and the sperm they're not necessarily
even different in size or shape so the
simplest eukaryotes produce what are
called motile gametes they're all like
sperm and they all swim around they find
each other they fuse together they don't
have kind of much
much going on there beyond that and then
these are
haploid which is to say we all have two
copies of our genome
and the the gametes have only a single
copy of the genome so when they fuse
together you now become diploid again
which is to say you now have two copies
of your genome and what you do is you
line them all up
um and then you and then you double
everything so now we have four copies of
the complete genome and then we cross
between all of these things so we take a
bit from here and stick it on there and
a bit from here and we stick it on here
that's recombination
um and and then we go through two rounds
of cell division so we divide in half so
now the two daughter cells have two
copies and we don't divide in half again
now we have some gametes each of which
has got a single copy of the genome
and that's the basic ground plan for
what's called meiosis and uh
basically sex
and it happens at the level of
single-celled organisms and it happens
pretty much the same way in plants and
pretty much the same way in animals and
so on and it's not found in any bacteria
they switch things around using the same
machinery and they take up a bit of dna
from the environment they take out this
bit and stick in that bit and it's the
same molecular machinery they're using
to do it so what about the kind of you
said find each other this kind of
imperative
yeah find each other
what is that
like is that well you've got a few cells
together
so the bottom the bottom line on all of
this is is is bacteria i mean it's kind
of simple uh when when you when you've
figured it out and figuring it out this
is not me this is my phd student marco
kolnagi um
and uh and
in effect if you if you're doing lateral
you're a nikolai cell
you've got 4 000 genes you want to scale
up to a eukaryotic size and i want to
have 20 000 genes um and i'm and i need
to maintain my genome so it doesn't get
shot to pieces by mutations and i'm
going to do it bilateral gene transfer
so
i know i've got a mutation in a gene i
don't know which gene it is because i'm
not sentient but i know i can't grow i
know all my regulation systems are
saying
something wrong here something wrong
pick up some dna pick up a bit of dna
from the environment
if you've got a small genome the chances
of you picking up the right bit of dna
from the environment is much higher than
if you've got a genome of 20 000 genes
to do that you've effectively got to be
picking up dna all the time all day long
and nothing else and you're still going
to get the wrong dna you've got to pick
up large chunks and in the end you've
got to align them you're forced
into sex to kind of phrase um
so yeah
so it's so there is a kind of uh
um incentive
uh if you want to have a large genome
you've got to prevent it mutating to
nothing that will happen with bacteria
there's another reason why bacteria
can't have a large genome but as soon as
you give them the power as soon as you
give you keratic cells the power pack
that allows them to increase the size of
their genome then you face the pressure
that you've got to maintain its quality
you've got to stop it just mutating away
what about sexual selection so the the
finding
uh like uh i don't like this one i don't
like this one this one seems all right
like what's the the the is is it at
which point does it become less random
it's hard to know
because your courier is just kind of
floating around i just kind of have yeah
there's everything that's there
sectionalization in single cell do you
care it's the probably is it's just that
i don't know very much about it by the
time you don't hang out with your
parents well i do all the time but i you
know but you can't communicate with them
yet yeah but for a
peacock or something yes um
the kind of standard this is not quite
what i work on but the standard answer
uh is that
it's female mate choice she is looking
for good genes um and and if you can
have a tale that's like this
and and and still survive still be alive
not actually being taken down by the
nearest predator then you must have got
pretty good genes because despite this
handicap
uh you're able to survive so so those
are like human interpretable things like
with a peacock but i wonder
i'm sure echoes of the same thing
are there with more primitive organisms
basically your pr like uh how you
advertise yourself that you're worthy
yeah of uh absolutely so one big
advertisement is the fact that you
survived it all
let me give you one one beautiful
example uh of an algal bloom
and this can be this can be a
cyanobacteria it can be in bacteria
so so if if suddenly you you know you
pump nitrate or phosphate or something
into the ocean and you everything goes
green you end up with all this
uh
algae growing there um a viral infection
or something like that
can kill the entire bloom overnight
and it's not that the virus takes out
everything overnight it's that most of
the cells in that bloom kill themselves
before the virus can get onto them
and it's through a form of cell death
called programmed cell death and we we
do the same thing this is how we have
the different you know the gaps between
our fingers and so on it's how we craft
synapses in the brain um it you know
it's fundamental again to to um to
multicellular life they have the same
machinery in these in these algal blooms
how do they know who dies the answer is
they will often put out a toxin
and that toxin
is a kind of a challenge to you either
you can cope with the toxin or you can't
if you can cope with it you form a spore
and you will go on to become the next
generation
you you form a kind of a resistance
spore you sink down a little bit you get
out of the way you're out of the out of
you can't be attacked by a virus if
you're a spore at least not so easily
whereas if you can't deal with that
toxin you pull the plug and you you you
you trigger your death apparatus and you
kill yourself because it's truly life
and death
yeah
so it's really it's a challenge and this
is a bit like sexual selection is it's
not so they're all pretty much
genetically identical but they've had
different life histories
so have you had a
tough day did you did you happen to get
infected by this virus or did you run
out of iron or did you get a bit too
much sun whatever it may be if this
extra stress of the toxin just pushes
you over the edge then you have this
binary choice either you're the next
generation or you kill yourself now
using this same machinery it's also
actually exactly the way i approach
dating but that
is probably why i'm single
you